jetzt geht es weiter mit einem ganz
spannenden Gesetz nennt sich
inflationsausgleichsgesetz die Grünen
und FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwürfe zum
Ausgleich der Inflation durch einen
fairen Einkommensteuertarif sowie zur
Anpassung weiterer steuerlicher
Regelungen und zur temporären Senkung
des Umsatzsteuersatzes auf
Gaslieferungen über das Erdgasnetz ich
bitte jetzt die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
doch
den Platz eigentlich geht es also um
zwei gesetzentwöhnliche Inflationen von
der SPD Bündnis 90 den Grünen und FDP
eingebracht einer befasst sich mit der
Senkung der Umsatzsteuer auf
Gaslieferungen und bei dem anderen
handelt es sich um das sogenannte
inflationsausgleichgesetz die Senkung
der Umsatzsteuer auf Gaslieferungen muss
man ja im Paket sehen mit der Diskussion
darum ob die Kunden ab dem 1 Oktober
jetzt beim Gas die 2,4 Cent zahlen
sollen pro Kilowattstunde oder nicht die
Bundesregierung hat sich entschieden das
vorläufig erst einmal so zu belassen bis
man dann uniter komplett übernommen hat
das ist in drei Monaten bis dahin wird
wohl noch viel diskutiert werden und ob
das dann wieder rückgängig gemacht wird
wollen wir mal sehen also jetzt hier als
erster Christian Lindner der
Bundesfinanzminister herr Präsident
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz und die
anderen steuerrechtlichen Regelungen die
die Bundesregierung vorschlägt sind Teil
der
krisenbewältigungsstrategie der
Koalition unser Land echt unter
galoppierenden Preisen das ist nicht
eine statistische Größe sondern es ist
für viele Menschen eine tägliche
Realität die Sorge um die
Nebenkostenabrechnung die Sorge ob die
Wohnung warm ist die Sorge ob am Ende
des Monats Geld dafür da ist den
Kühlschrank zu füllen die Inflation ist
eine Bedrohung für Wohlstand soziale
Sicherheit und die Stabilität unseres
Landes und deshalb ist die erste
Priorität der Bundesregierung diese
Inflation zu bekämpfen niemand wird
dabei allein gelassen
um soziale Härten abzufedern haben wir
zahlreiche Maßnahmen beschlossen
beispielsweise steht eine wohngeldreform
an es wird auch darum gehen
wirtschaftliche strukturbrüche zu
verhindern eigentlich gesunde Betriebe
die sichere und gut bezahlte
arbeitsplatzplätze über Jahre und
Jahrzehnte angeboten haben stehen
angesichts der explodierenden Gaspreise
vor größten und existenziellen
Herausforderungen die Bundesregierung
ist sich auch dieser Tatsache bewusst
und arbeitet deshalb unter Hochdruck
sowohl an Maßnahmen zur Bekämpfung der
hohen Strompreise als auch an Maßnahmen
um die gegenwärtigen Gaspreise für
unsere Wirtschaft nicht zu einer
dauerhaften Gefahr werden zu lassen
daneben gibt es aber auch Menschen die
ihren Lebensunterhalt bestreiten ohne
soziale Unterstützung Menschen in der
Mitte der Gesellschaft und auch diese
Menschen dürfen während der Inflation
nicht allein gelassen werden und deshalb
hat sich die Koalition darauf
verständigt dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz vorzulegen
unsere fiskalpolitische Antwort auf die
Inflation ist insofern zweigeteilt zum
einen geht es darum dass Angebot
auszuweiten weil das Preise dämpft
darüber beraten wir im Bereich der
Energieerzeugung siehe die Debatte zuvor
dafür weiten wir die
Produktionskapazitäten erneuerbarer wie
ich sie in eine freiheitsenergien aus
dafür werden wir auch die lng-terminals
in Deutschland
an das Netz bringen also angebotsausweis
die Frage aber jawohl die Ratifizierung
von ceta ist ebenfalls geplant und das
könnte auch nur der Beginn einer
erweiterten Handelspolitik sein aber
daneben Kollege Spahn geht es auch darum
dafür zu sorgen dass wir nicht
realwirtschaftlich eine weitere
krisenverschärfung erleben bei aller
Notwendigkeit sich auf das Angebot zu
konzentrieren darf auf der anderen Seite
die Nachfrage nicht komplett einbrechen
weil sonst andere Bereiche im
dienstleistungs- und dem Konsumbereich
sonst angesteckt würden und aus diesem
Grund kommt auch zur
Inflationsbekämpfung diesen
inflationsausgleichsgesetz eine
besondere Bedeutung zu weil es nämlich
die Kaufkraft in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft erhält und dafür sorgt das
andere eigentlich stabile Branchen im
Bereich Dienstleistung und Handel nicht
zusätzlich infiziert werden
das allerdings da ist allerdings
lediglich ein Kaufkraft Ausgleich an
Inflationsausgleich ist fügt sich dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz in die von
uns vertretene fiskalische Neutralität
ein wir wollen nachfragen und Wachstum
in dieser Phase der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung nichts stimulieren wir
wollen allerdings auch nicht durch
zusätzliche kontraktive Maßnahmen die
Nachfrage in bestimmten Bereichen
Bremsen also wir folgen der fiskalischen
Neutralität insofern gehen deutsche
Fiskalpolitik und Notenbankpolitik der
EZB auch in diesem Fall Hand in Hand wir
verändern den Grundfreibetrag den Tarif
wir erhöhen das Kindergeld und den
Kinderfreibetrag 48 Millionen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger profitieren von
diesen
inflationsausgleichsgesetz es basiert
auf vorläufigen Zahlen um gleich ein
Argument der Opposition vorwegzunehmen
das war auch immer so es ist hier
sozusagen ein trägergesetz dessen
konkrete Zahlen zu aktualisieren sind
wenn die Herbstprognose vorliegt das war
immer so und ist technisch nicht anders
zu lösen auf der Basis der bisherigen
Werte
erhält eine Familie vier Köpfe also mit
zwei Kindern einen inflations- und mit
56.000 Euro zu versteuerndem Einkommen
im Jahr erhält ein Inflationsausgleich
von
680 Euro im kommenden Jahr anders
gewendet würden wir nichts tun würde
diese Familie 680 Euro an Kaufkraft
verlieren angesichts der enormen
Preissteigerung und diese familien
zahlen für ihr Gas ohne eine
Unterstützung angesichts der enormen
Preissteigerungen ist das nur gerecht
dass die arbeitende Mittel der
Gesellschaft ebenfalls bedacht wird
ich appelliere
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich appelliere an die
Länder diesen inflationsausgleichsgesetz
zuzustimmen es geht darum die Menschen
vor zusätzlichen Belastungen in einer
Phase der Inflation zu schützen es kann
nicht sein dass der Staat von der
Inflation profitiert während Familie
nicht mehr wissen wie sie mit ihrem
Einkommen über die Runden kommen sollen
während selbstständige belastet sind
profitiert der Staat das kann nicht sein
und was für den Bund gilt dass er nicht
Profiteur von Inflation sein will das
muss in gleicher Weise auch für die
Länder gelten es gibt nicht nur
finanzierungsnotwendigkeiten beim Staat
es gibt nicht nur
es gibt auch private
finanzierungsnotwendigkeiten und
zwischen diesen beiden schaffen wir eine
faire Balance mit diesem
Gesetzgebungsvorhaben
vielen Dank Herr Minister der
Bundesfinanzminister hat noch einmal
vorgestellt warum ich so wichtig ist
auch die kalte Progression abzubauen
laut dem Gesetzentwurf wird die
anpassungsstelle Mindereinnahmen in Höhe
von 12,2 Milliarden Euro im Jahr 2023
für eine knapp 18 Milliarden 2024
Matthias Mittelberg für die Union dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz richtig und
beglückwünschen sie dazu Herr Minister
dass sie das in ihrer Koalition
durchgesetzt haben das ist ein guter
Baustein in diesem Entlastungspaket
klarer Aussage aber und das haben sie ja
auch gesagt
es ist im Grunde eine
Selbstverständlichkeit denn durch diese
kalte Progression die ja gerade entsteht
durch den doppelten Effekt die Leute
kriegen Lohnerhöhung wandern im
einkommenssteuertarif höher werden höher
besteuert gleichzeitig verlieren sie
durch die massive Inflation an Kaufkraft
durch diesen doppelten Effekt wird das
Einkommen der Menschen entwertet und das
wollen wir ausgleichen indem jetzt die
Steuerschraube ein Stück zurückdrehen
und den Steuertarif Anpassen an die
Einkommensentwicklung das ist nichts
anderes als den Menschen eigentlich das
zurückzugeben was sie sonst durch eine
schleichende Steuererhöhung an leid ich
hätte fast gesagt an Verlusten erfahren
hätten nicht mehr als das es ist im
Grunde genommen sie haben ja lange über
dieses Thema übergewinde diskutiert es
ist die Rückgabe von übergewinnen die
dieser Staat macht auf Kosten der
Inflationsentwicklung mehr ist es nicht
wir haben dieses Verfahren der
Vermeidung von schleichenden
Steuererhöhungen schon seit 2012
eingerichtet im übrigen damals in der
gemeinsamen Regierung mit der FDP
seitdem gibt es dieses Verfahren wir
kriegen regelmäßig alle zwei Jahre die
progressionsberichte passen daraufhin
den Steuertarif an und das ist richtig
so dass sie das jetzt auch so machen
aber sie erwecken den Eindruck sie
würden hier jetzt wahnsinnige
Anstrengungen unternehmen um diese
Geschichte und auch ihr Entlastungspaket
auf die Beine zu bringen sie schreiben
das auch in ihrem entlastungspapier die
begrenzten finanziellen Spielräume
erfordern erhebliche Anstrengungen aller
drei Koalitionspartner wenn man sich
allerdings ihre Haushaltsplanung ansieht
und ihre sonstigen Planungen kann man
von diesen Anstrengungen nicht so
wirklich was erkennen wir erkennen kaum
Punkte an denen sie mal Einsparung oder
Umschichtungen oder neu Priorisierungen
vornehmen sondern im Grunde genommen
machen Sie alle Ihre Projekte wie bisher
und die hier veranstalten ist lediglich
den Leuten das Geld zurückzugeben was
sie ihnen vorher durch höhere und
deutlich gestiegene Steuern aus der
Tasche gezogen haben sie haben nämlich
in diesem Jahr alleine bei der
Umsatzsteuer Bund Länder und Kommunen
gemeinsam annähernd 50 Milliarden
Mehreinnahmen gegenüber dem letzten Jahr
ich sage es noch mal 50 Milliarden
für jeden nachvollziehbar weil die
Preise ja so exorbiton steigen und Sie
darauf die Mehrwertsteuer zahlen und
deswegen verdient der Staat an dieser
Inflationsentwicklung massiv 50
Milliarden davon fast die Hälfte beim
Bund
so für dieses Jahr für dieses Jahr geben
Sie den progressionseffekt ja gar nicht
zurück sondern erst für das nächste Jahr
ihr Gesetz was wir heute hier
beschließen das wird ja erst fürs
nächste Jahr das heißt die 10 Milliarden
die der Bund in diesem Jahr zusätzlich
einnimmt die stecken Sie einfach mal
eben so ein und tun jetzt ganz großzügig
so bei ihrem Entlastungspaket als würden
sie den Leuten was zurückgeben sie haben
es den Leuten vorher aus der Tasche
gezogen und nichts anderes und wenn Sie
das Addieren die 25 Milliarden und die
10 Milliarden die sie an mehr Einnahmen
an Mehreinnahmen nur der Bund gegenüber
letztem Jahr haben dann sind das locker
mehr als die 32 Milliarden Beitrag des
Bundes zum Entlastungspaket insgesamt
ich will Ihnen was sagen
und Herr Minister Lindner hat ja auch
über das Gesetz hinausgesprochen ich
glaube dass die Menschen in diesem Land
das hat auch die vorhergehende Debatte
gezeigt
allmählich das Vertrauen verlieren dass
diese ihre Regierung diese
problematische Situation die größte
Energiekrise Europas seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg
eine rieseninflation seit höher als seit
40 Jahren dass ihre Regierung diese
dramatische Lage für dieses Land
wirklich in den Griff kriegt ich glaube
dass die Leute da das Vertrauen
allmählich verlieren und zwar einfach
vor dem Hintergrund sie haben den ganzen
Sommer über verplempert durch interne
Streitereien die sie bis zum heutigen
Tage hier zum Thema Verlängerung der
Kernkraftwerke fortführen die ganze Zeit
erleben wir wie sie untereinander
zerstritten sind der Kollege Spahn hat
eben völlig zu Recht gesagt Herr Harbeck
hat uns gestern aufgefordert wir sollen
da mal die Regierung unterstützen in
dieser schwierigen Phase ja wir würden
es gerne machen nur wir wissen nicht wen
wir in der Regierung unterstützen sollen
wir ein Harbeck unterstützen sollen wir
Herrn Lindner unterstützen wen sollen
wir denn eigentlich unterstützen
vielleicht werden sie sich selbst mal
einig
sie machen eine völlig verfehlte Politik
ein Fehler nach dem anderen erst machen
sie entlastungspakete wo sie nicht
zielgenau entlassen sondern das Geld mit
der Gießkanne irgendwie verstreuen dann
vergessen sie ganze Bevölkerungsgruppen
Rentner und Studierende haben Sie von
Anfang an gar nicht auf dem Schirm
gehabt das Holen Sie jetzt mühselig nach
die Leute die am unteren Ende der Skala
verdienen die schneiden bei ihnen am
schlechtesten ab die Kohlekraftwerke das
ist ihnen eben vorgehalten worden und
zwar zu Recht haben sich viel zu spät
jetzt hochgefahren das hat dazu geführt
und führt noch immer dazu dass wir
sinnlos Gas verbrennen dass wir zum
Heizen viel dringender bräuchten als für
die Stromproduktion
ihre gasumlage ist der absolute Mist und
zwar von der Konstruktion her und sie
ist auch rechtlich völlig unsicher und
Sie haben ja noch nicht mal geklärt in
ihrer Regierung ob sie das rechtlich
überhaupt noch durchsetzen können das
ist doch eine Katastrophe und jetzt
erklärt eben Herr Lindner hier ja beim
Strompreis und Gaspreis da werden wir
noch was machen das ist aber doch das
was die Menschen am meisten beschäftigt
ihr ganzes Entlastungspaket ist doch
nichts wert wenn Sie an diesen beiden
entscheidenden Punkten noch nicht
weiterkommen und bisher sie haben sie
immer noch nichts konkretes dazu
geliefert das ist doch eine Katastrophe
keiner kann planen kein Unternehmer kein
Mittelständler kein Betrieb weiß was
Sache ist die müssen davon ausgehen dass
sie am 31.12 ihren Laden dicht machen
aber das macht ja nichts die produzieren
ja nur nicht weiter und verkaufen
einfach nicht weiter das bleibt ja
folgenlos wie der Wirtschaftsminister
uns erklärt hat
der Habeck hat gesagt wir hätten nur ein
Gas und kein Stromproblem das müssen sie
den Leuten wirklich angesichts der
Strompreise die durch die Decke gehen
erklären und dass sie jetzt in der
größten Energiekrise dieses Landes in
der größten Energiekrise Europas drei
funktionierende Kraftwerke die für die
Versorgung von 10 Millionen Haushalten
einstehen dass sie die vom Netz nehmen
wollen das ist schlicht unverantwortlich
der eine Baustein über den wir heute
sprechen Inflationsausgleich gesetzt ist
okay aber ansonsten müssen sie noch ganz
massiv Nacharbeiten wir sind gerne
bereit Ihnen dabei zu helfen aber Sie
müssen sich dann ehrlich machen aber Sie
müssen sich dann ehrlich machen und sie
müssen das Umsetzen wovon ihr Kanzler
selber spricht nämlich zeitenwände das
heißt auch dass sie was wenden müssen
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Mittelberg
des der Begriff Zeitenwende trifft dann
auch wir Redner zu nicht die sollen
vielleicht mal auf die Uhr gucken und
die Zeiten einhalten nächster Redner ist
der Kollege Michael schrodi SPD-Fraktion
Michael schrodi ist finanzpolitischer
Sprecher der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren die
Bundesrepublik ist leider der größten
Herausforderungen seit ihrem Bestehen so
wie in anderen
krisenhaften Zeiten wie beispielsweise
in der Pandemie als die Bundeskanzlerin
Angela Merkel und der
Bundesfinanzminister Olaf Scholz gesagt
haben auch mit einem damaligen Begriff
der Bazooka belassen die BürgerInnen
Bürger die Unternehmen nicht alleine sie
werden Sie gut durch die Pandemie
bringen so hat auch in dieser
Herausforderung der Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz auch jetzt der
Bundesfinanzminister für diese
Bundesregierung klar gemacht niemand
bleibt alleine wir werden gemeinsam
alles tun damit die Menschen in diesem
Land damit die Unternehmen diesem Land
solidarisch und gut durch diese
Herausforderung kommen
um über die richtigen Maßnahmen zu
sprechen muss man sich aber anschauen
was die Ursachen für die Teuerungsraten
und da gibt es in der Debatte einige
grundlegende Fehldiagnosen wie gestern
auch beispielsweise Professor truger und
kommen einem Antrag der cocsu in einer
Anhörung deutlich gemacht haben zum
ersten zur ganzrechten Ecke zur fünften
Kanal
es ist der völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffskrieg Russlands es ist Putin der
Energie als Waffe nutzt es ist derjenige
der den Preis für das Gas hochtrepp das
sage ich nur Experten auch die
Bundesbank macht deutlich das Gas das
Energie die Preise hochtreibt er will
unsere Gesellschaft damit
destabilisieren das wird Putin und das
wird ihnen von der AFD nicht gelingen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
und es sind angebotsschocks es sind drei
Schocks wegen Energieknappheit es ist
nicht die Geldpolitik es ist nicht
explantive Start in die Teuerungsraten
jetzt verursacht deswegen gibt es auch
eine Warnung an der Stelle das weitere
große zinsprünge in einer sich anbahnen
Rezession eine tiefe Wirtschaftskrise
mit sich bringen könnten und das auch
jetzt
ausbleibende Investitionen der
Bundesfinanzminister hat ja gesagt wir
brauchen jetzt klare Signale an die
Wirtschaft auch dass wir ihn in dieser
Phase aber auch in der Erholung helfen
dass diese Signale jetzt kommen damit
wir gut aus dieser Krise herauskommen
die Signale haben wir aufgenommen
gestern wurde übrigens alle Vorschläge
Herr Merz der cdu/csu von Experten als
überholt als nicht zielführend beurteilt
50 Milliarden mehr Ausgaben ohne jede
Gegenfinanzierung ich erinnere Sie noch
Herr märz an ihre Forderungen im März
ein Gas in bargut durchzusetzen was das
bedeutet hätte wissen Sie heute ganz
genau wir wussten es damals schon es ist
unsinnig was sie fordern in dieser
Krisenbekämpfung und das bedauere ich
weil wir eine gemeinsame Anstrengung
brauchen um diese Herausforderungen
anzunehmen ich bedaue es sehr dass dich
hilfreichere auch Unterstützung von
Seiten Opposition kommt dass ihr
vorliegende Inflationsausgleich das ist
eine hilfreiche Maßnahme den Menschen in
dieser Herausforderungen Situation zu
helfen aber es ist bei weitem der
Bundesfinanzminister hat gesagt nicht
die einzige Maßnahme insgesamt circa 100
Milliarden Euro
sind es die wir jetzt mobilisieren in
den Entlastungspaket dabei gibt es zwei
große
Ziele zum einen wir wollen und wir
werden die hohen Energiepreise senken
deshalb begrüßen wir sowohl die
Beschlüsse des Koalitionsausschusses wie
auch jetzt die Forderungen und die
Vorschläge der Kommission mit einer
strompreisbremse und auch mit einer
Bremse für Gas und andere fossile
Energieträger
krisenbedingte übergewinne abzuschöpfen
und damit den Grundbedarf an Strom an
Gas günstiger zu machen das hilft
VerbraucherInnen Verbrauchern das hilft
Unternehmen das senkt die Inflation und
ist auch eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit
und deswegen geben wir das auch anders
Bundesregierung
und wir wissen aus aktuellen Zahlen dass
es gerade die Menschen die Familien mit
kleinem mittleren Einkommen sind die an
stärksten von den Teuerungsraten
betroffen sind die reichen wir am besten
Direktzahlungen wie dem Kinderbonus mit
den 300 Euro
energiepreispauschal die jetzt
ausgezahlt werden die wir auch für die
Rentner Rentner auf den Weg bringen mit
heizkostenzuschussisch auch mit 200 Euro
für Studierende und wir reichen
Entlastungen auch mit
Steuerentlastungen indem wir jetzt in
diesen
inflationsausgleichsgesetz Entlastungen
schaffen ganz konkret wir erhöhen das
Kindergeld für 2023 und ziehen die
Erhöhung für 2024 vor das hilft vor
allem Familien mit kleinen mittleren
Einkommen wir erhöhen den
Kinderfreibetrag rückwirkend Herr
Mittelberg für 2022 und für die nächsten
beiden Jahre und sie haben nicht
aufgepasst weil wir gesagt haben wir
haben bisher die wirk der Inflation der
kalten Progression nicht ausgeglichen
wir haben auch den Grundfreibetrag
rückwirkend für 2022 angeglichen das ist
genau das was wir tun beim Bekämpfung
der kalten Progression und wir tun das
jetzt für 2023 und auch für 2024 auf
einen Grundfreibetrag von
10.932,2 große Schritte und wir gleichen
auch wie die letzten Jahre auch die
sogenannte kalte Progression aus damit
Lohnerhöhungen nicht von höherem
Steuertarif und Inflation aufgefressen
werden im Oktober kommen dazu
Existenzminimum und
steuerprogressionsbericht da passen wir
die Werte noch mal an in den letzten
Jahren haben wir übrigens
überkompensiert auf Basis der Zahlen die
uns damals Vorlagen und gerade in diesem
Jahr werden wir aber genau darauf achten
das in der Situation in der kleinen
mittlere Einkommen hart getroffen sind
die soziale Balance auch zu wahren bei
allen Maße auch bei dieser eine kleine
mittlere Einkommen noch mehr entlastet
werden als das vorgesehen ist bisher
viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
bedanke mich auch ganz ausdrücklich bei
den Bundesländern der
Bundesfinanzminister hat es angesprochen
wir brauchen dazu jetzt auch die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in den Ländern
ich nehme wahr dass es da bei einer
kritischen Anmerkungen eine
grundsätzliche Zustimmung gibt denn auch
die Länder wissen und dann ist auch
begründet dass es eine große
Herausforderung ist an sich auch die
Länder beitragen wollen damit es noch im
Detail Verhandlungen geben ich bin guter
Dinge dass wir die auch zu einem guten
Abschluss bringen werden was aber nicht
geht
ist wenn beispielsweise der bayerische
Ministerpräsident Markus Söder jetzt aus
diese Thema parteitaktische Spielchen
spielt auch die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und die Unternehmen in Bayern brauchen
diese Hilfe man kann nicht immer sagen
mir sanier und wenn es darum geht
wirklich was zu tun mir schlagen uns in
die Büsche das ist nicht angemessen in
der Situation in der wir gerade sind ich
bin guter Dinge freue mich auf die
weiteren Beratung dieses Gesetzes ein
wichtiger weiterer Baustein um
Entlastungen auf dem Weg zu bringen in
dieser schwierigen Situation und bedanke
mich für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege schrodi
als nächster Redner Held der Kollege
Karl Gottschalk afd-fraktion das Wort
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Herr Schrot ich
glaube sie waren gestern in einer
anderen Expertenanhörung sie haben die
vielen kritischen Anmerkungen glaube ich
nicht gehört aber ich will da gar nicht
drauf eingehen das ist es nicht wert
meine Damen und Herren von der
schuldenkoalition das vorgelegte
inflationsausgleichsgesetz soll laut
Bundesfinanzministerium entschuldigen
Sie dass sich da lache es ist traurig
genug 48 Millionen Bürger entlasten das
Gesetz soll weiterhin ich zitiere mit
Erlaubnis des Präsidenten
inflationsbedingte Mehrbelastungen
ausgleichen sie wissen schon was
ausgleichen heißt hoffe ich indem die
Steuerlast die in der Inflation
angepasst wird und schon hier beginnt
das Gesetz mit einer glatten Lüge meine
Damen und Herren
den übrigen Herr schroti gute Politik
und ein guter portfolio-mix in der
Energie hätte dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz komplett
unnötig gemacht es geht vor allem und
das sei hier adressiert um die kalte
Progression und schon jetzt Herr Lindner
weiß die Bundesregierung dass der
Ausgleich aus ihrem Gesetz aller
Voraussicht nach nicht immer
entferntesten die Inflation vollständig
ausgleichen wird auf welcher ein Wunder
die Bundesbank muss innerhalb von 12
Monaten zum dritten Mal ihre
Inflationsprognose korrigieren wir sind
in mittlerweile bei einer 10 bei einer
zweistelligen Prognose der Bundesbank
und wie ich im Deutschland Kurier
bereits im Januar prognostizierte werden
wir eine Inflation zwischen fünf und
sieben Prozent erhalten meine Damen und
Herren aus unserer Sicht ist also dieses
vorgelegte Gesetz wieder einmal nur ein
bewusstes ausschieben Herr Kollege
schrodi denn jetzt ist schon klar dass
die Änderung bei den tarifeckwirt da
hören sie gut zu das ist Mathematik ich
hoffe den können sie folgen die ja
Grundlage der Vermeidung der kalten
Progression sind erst ab 23 gelten
sollen ab 23 in welcher Welt leben Sie
denn wir haben seit Januar 22 eine
galoppierende Inflation dieses Gesetz
müsste eigentlich in der Überschrift
heißen der fleißige ist der Dumme meine
Damen und Herren
und dass sie nicht auf dem
progressionsbericht warten müssten das
haben sie eben Herr schrodi auch gut
dokumentiert sie haben nämlich betont
und das ist richtig der Grundfreibetrag
yippie-jahr ist ja erhöht worden damals
haben sie wahrscheinlich wieder nicht
zugehört alle Experten sogar die eigenen
von ihrem Gewerkschaftsbund haben gesagt
die Erhöhung des Grundfreibetrages ist
jetzt schon unzureichend und leicht
entfernt das nicht die Inflation auf
meine Damen und Herren also hören Sie
sich auf sich hier als Vertreter der
kleinen Leute zugerieren das sind sie
schon lange nicht mehr erschrodi
es ist in keinster Weise nachvollziehbar
dass ihr die Bürger bei dieser
galoppierenden Inflation nicht zu
reichend und tatsächlich nachhaltig um
dieses schöne Wort hier mal zu
strapazieren entlasten aber nähern wir
uns des Pudels Kern meine Damen und
Herren von der schuldenkoalition der
größte Profiteur ist eben bei der kalten
Progression und das sagen auch alle
wissenschaftlichen Abhandlungen dazu der
Staat sie können ohne dass sie den
Bürger hier im Hohen Hause klar machen
müssen durch Steuererhöhung und
Diskussion Mehreinnahmen gerieren das
hat der Kollege Wiener das haben andere
Kollegen hier vor mir eben wunderbar
dargelegt der Fehler liegt im System
meine Damen und Herren die afd-fraktion
fordert mittlerweile seit vielen Jahren
nehmen Sie sich doch endlich der Idee
des Bundes der Steuerzahler an entlasten
Sie automatisch wie es andere Länder die
Schweiz tun den Tarif auf Rädern fordern
wir seit drei Jahren sie folgen nicht
und die FDP hat immer noch im
Wahlprogramm stehen meine Damen und
Herren
und im übrigen die tariferklärte sind
doch nur die eine Wahrheit sie müssten
genauso die Höchstgrenzen die
Freibeträge die pauschalen
beispielsweise die Pendlerpauschale
meine Damen und Herren seit 2004
unzureichen ab dem 21 Kilometer mal
erhöht erhöhen meine Damen und Herren
auch das ist eine Entwicklung haben sie
gestern nicht gehört glaube ich Herr
schrodi als einige Sachverständige das
zur Sprache brachten auch hier tun sie
nichts aber in Wirklichkeit machen Sie
sich doch endlich ehrlich wollen Sie
dieses perpeto und mobile der heimlichen
steuerabzocke beibehalten das ist genau
Ihr Problem meine Damen und Herren
und Herr Lindner sagen sich dem Menschen
doch offen und ehrlich dass sie auch
hier mittlerweile leider den Predigern
ihrer Koalition auf den Leim gegangen
sind in Wirklichkeit ist doch das was
sie hier tun die kalte Progression die
neue Reichensteuer und den Mittelstand
und die Mittelschicht haben sie als neue
Opfer dieser Politik ausgemacht und das
ist schändlich eine FDP die sowas
mitmacht gehört in den nächsten
Bundestag nicht mehr hinein meine Damen
und Herren
Herr Kollege bitte kommt
konstruktiv an den Diskussionen
beteiligen und freuen uns auf die
Beratung vielen Dank
das war der finanzpolitische Sprecher
der afd-bundestagsfraktion Kai
Gottschalk hat so ein bisschen überzogen
wurde dann auch von Präsidenten
angezählt und jetzt der nächste Redner
in der Debatte Andreas audritsch ist der
stellvertretende zuständige
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzender
der Bündnis Grünen
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir stehen vor
dem schwierigen Winter die Krise in der
wir uns befinden droht sich in der
sozialen Schärfe und auch in der Schärfe
für Unternehmen und den Auswirkungen
weiter zu verschlimmern das ist die
Folie vor der wir heute dieses Gesetz
beraten wir Grüne sind der Überzeugung
dass wir uns in dieser Krise
konzentrieren müssen dass wir uns
konzentrieren müssen auf Menschen mit
wenig Geld auf die mit kleinen Einkommen
auf die mit mittleren Einkommen und die
Abschaffung der kalten Progression und
das haben wir über den Sommer sehr
häufig gesagt das gilt auch jetzt
entlastet vor allem die reichsten das
ist nicht unser Instrument das ist nicht
das was wir vorgeschlagen haben und es
ist jetzt in der Krise das falsche
Instrument
warum warum tragen warum tragen wir es
trotzdem mit und das ist die
erklärungsbedürftig wenn ich so diese
Rede beginne warum tragen wir es dennoch
mit weil es Teil eines größeren Paketes
ist und so funktioniert Demokratie meine
Damen und Herren es ist Teil eines
größeren Paketes wo wir auch die Dinge
verankert haben die wir jetzt in dieser
Krise für relevant und für wichtig
erachten ich will das an einem Beispiel
machen uns geht es um Familien die wenig
Geld haben deswegen wollen wir dass das
Kindergeld angehoben wird deswegen
wollen wir und das gehört dezidiert dazu
dass auch der Kinderzuschlag angehoben
würden auf diese Sachen werden wir in
der Umsetzung im parlamentarischen
Verfahren achten das wird für uns im
Mittelpunkt stehen und in diesem Sinne
ist es ein gutes Paket und ein Paket
dass wir jetzt gemeinsam tragen können
wir alle wissen die Krise ist nicht zu
Ende die es bei weitem nicht zu Ende die
Institute prognostizieren eine Rezession
Unternehmen Krankenhäuser soziale
Einrichtungen sie alle wenden sich an
uns mit der Bitte um Hilfe und wir
werden Ihnen allen eine angemessene
Antwort geben müssen das bedeutet zum
einen dass wir Energiekosten senken das
bedeutet aber auch dass wir bereit sein
müssen mehr Hilfe zu leisten Robert
Habeck weitet das Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm auf kleine und
mittlere Unternehmen aus auf
Handwerksbetriebe das geht um
Traditionsunternehmen das geht um die
Bäckerei um die Ecke das geht um die
kleinen Städte vor Ort all die wollen
wir jetzt unterstützen dafür brauchen
wir einen zweistelligen Milliardenbetrag
der jetzt ausgegeben werden der muss
jetzt zur Verfügung gestellt werden
damit wir unsere Unternehmen schützen
wir Grüne sagen sehr deutlich und auch
heute hier in der Debatte wir stehen
hinter unseren Unternehmen wir stehen an
der Seite unsere Unternehmen und wir
werden dafür arbeiten dass die Hilfe nun
schnell und geht da ankommt wo sie
gebraucht wird
und auch dann ist klar dass die Antwort
damit nicht gegeben ist eine Kommission
arbeitet gerade an der Frage nach einem
gaspreisdeckel für Verbraucher und klar
ist doch um mit den hohen Gaspreisen am
Ende umzugehen egal wie es rauskommt
werden wir Geld brauchen das wird viel
Geld kosten da brauchen wir die Augen
nicht vor zu verschließen von den
krankenhaushäusern kriegen wir Notrufe
weil sie die Energiekosten nicht mehr
tragen können wie sie im Moment sich
ihnen darstellt und selbstverständlich
muss der Bund auch an der Stelle
reingehen und Unterstützung leisten wir
können es uns nicht leisten dass wir in
dieser Krise die soziale Infrastruktur
die Krankenhäuser die sozialen
Pflegeeinrichtungen alles was dieses
Land im Kern an sozialer Infrastruktur
hat was das beschädigt wird das können
wir uns nicht leisten deswegen werden
wir auch an der Stelle die entsprechende
Hilfe leisten müssen und bei alledem
steht am Ende eine Frage im Raum das ist
die Frage der Finanzierung
und wir können angesichts einer
drohenden Rezession nicht tatenlos
zusehen dass Schaden im Kern unserer
Wirtschaft entsteht das können wir nicht
machen wir können nicht zusehen dass
Schaden im Kern unserer sozialen
Infrastruktur entsteht jetzt ist der
Moment wo wir investieren müssen jetzt
ist der Moment wo wir Geld in die Hand
nehmen müssen und das ist gut werden
kann haben wir bei rosenheft gesehen wir
müssen jetzt investieren so bekämpfen
wir die Rezession nur so können wir aus
der Inflation rauskommen weil wir
wegkommen von den fossilen Energien und
nur so schaffen wir jetzt auch die
Transformation und bekämpfen die
Klimakrise lasst es uns lassen Sie es
uns gemeinsam machen Geld in die Hand
nehmen und einen Weg finden der jetzt
die Probleme angeht und gleichzeitig
eine Perspektive für die Zukunft öffnet
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Andrej
die Bundestag diskutiert über zwei
Gesetzentwürfe der Ampel einer befasst
sich mit der Senkung der Umsatzsteuer
auf Gaslieferungen bei dem anderen
handelt es sich um das sogenannte
inflationsausgleichsgesetz und jetzt
Christian Görke
normalen Zeiten ist die Anpassung der
Steuertarife an die Inflation richtig
und es ist Pflichtprogramm aber wir
haben ja eine handfeste ausgemachte
Krise und deshalb müssen wir mehr tun
und nicht gebetsmügen artig wie der
Bundesfinanzminister sehr jeden Tag tut
sich an die Schuldenbremse Ketten und
mittlerweile ist es ja auch so dass sie
der letzte sind an Bord mittlerweile ist
hier die Union mit Markus Söder verlässt
ja auch schon das sinkende Schiff der
Schuldenbremse und dann das noch ihr
inflationsausgleichsgesetz das dem Dax
Manager 479 Euro beschert der
Kassiererin 150 Euro und der friseurinne
Teilzeit wird gar nicht entlastet passt
doch nicht in unsere Zeit ebenso wenig
sehr geehrter Herr Finanzminister dass
Sie sich hier auf die Schulter klopfen
aber ein Großteil der Rechnung eben bei
den Kommunen und den Ländern ablegen
auch das geht nicht nun aber zur
gasumlage und damit zur
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Gas diese
Umlage meine Damen und Herren und das
sehen Sie jetzt auch ist eine der
größten Fehlleistungen dieser Regierung
das haben sie auch mittlerweile
eingesehen sonst würden wir ja heute
nicht über die Mehrwertsteuersenkung
beim gasreden erst Umlage dann
Steuersenkung das gesamte wirver was
hier anstellen hätten sich doch schenken
können wenn sie wenn sie das
Minusgeschäft der kritischen
gasinfrastruktur aus dem Bundeshaushalt
abgefangen hätten so wie sie es bei den
Banken gemacht haben so wie sie es bei
der Lufthansa realisiert haben
stattdessen wird den Verbraucherinnen
und Verbrauchern die Rechnung in die
ohnehin explodierende
Nebenkostenrechnung gesteckt das sind
die Fakten und noch mal ganz klar zu
sagen diese Steuersenkung auf Gas ist
keine Entlastung
es ist nur eine bürokratische
Wiedergutmachung von einer unsäglichen
Belastung durch diese gasumlage und das
ist ein Himmel weiter Unterschied meine
Damen und Herren wir wissen ja alle um
die gedächtnisschwächen des
Bundeskanzlers aber dass er auch noch
schlecht in Mathe war und ist das hat
mich schon überrascht und deshalb möchte
ich von der Pressekonferenz zum Thema
Senkung Mehrwertsteuer ihn auch zitieren
ich zitiere mit diesem Schritt entlasten
wir die Gaskunden insgesamt deutlich
stärker als die Mehrbelastung die durch
die gasumlage entsteht das stimmt so
nicht wie stark die Gaskunden entlastet
werden hängt nämlich von dem Vertrag ab
das einzige was stimmt je teurer die er
Vertrag dann kommt irgendwann
proportionell eine Entlastung hinterher
aber wer noch einen alten günstigen
Vertrag hat der zahlt bei dieser
Steuersenkung noch oben drauf und
überhaupt ist es sowieso eine
Milchmädchenrechnung 20 Milliarden Euro
von den insgesamt 34 30 Milliarden
umfasst den Umlage entfällt auf Firmen
und an denen das kam ja schon der
Zwischenruf läuft ja die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung ja vorbei aber was
wird der Bäckermeister und was wären die
Unternehmen dann tun mit dieser Umlage
sie werden sie weitergehen das heißt
diese 20 Milliarden Euro landen auch
noch bei den Verbraucherinnen und
Verbrauchern mit einer zusätzlichen
Belastung mit einem zusätzlichen
Preisschock und natürlich noch mit dem
Anstieg bei der Inflation und deshalb
meine Damen und Herren das ist doch
völlig irre was sie hier machen völlig
irre und Pizza deshalb muss dieser
soziale und volkswirtschaftliche Unsinn
vom Tisch meine Damen und Herren
lassen sie mich zum Abschluss noch ein
Gedanken äußern für den weiteren Verlauf
der parlamentarischen Debatte wenn sie
schon die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas
anfassen warum nicht auch den Steuersatz
auf der Fernwärme der Betrieb 19 Prozent
und könnte auch auf 7% runtergesetzt
werden denn die Fernwärme wird ja
überwiegend aus Gas gespeist und damit
würden sie sechs Millionen Haushalte vor
allen Dingen in Ostdeutschland entlassen
die natürlich in Ostdeutschland herrscht
noch ein gutes fernwärmesystem vor
entlasten wird das wäre doch mal ein
Beitrag und insofern freue ich mich auf
die weitere Debatte vielen Dank
vielen Dank
Christian Görke war das von der Linken
die gasumlage 34 Milliarden Euro werden
da fällig werden vom Bürger aber da ist
ja wie gesagt vielleicht das letzte Wort
noch nicht diskutiert Marcus Herbern
jetzt für die FDP Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gäbe einiges
richtig zu stellen aus der Debatte ich
möchte mich zunächst auch an die
Kollegen der CDU wenden Herr Kollege
Middelberg bei allem Respekt wenn sie
uns gießkannenpolitik vorwerfen dann
empfehle ich Ihnen die Lektüre ihrer
Anträge zum infektionsausgleich
also so viel Gießkanne mehr Gießkanne
geht überhaupt nicht meine sehr geehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir leben in
Zeiten größter Unsicherheit 8-prozentige
Inflation mindestens einen sinkendes
Wirtschaftswachstum das sorgt für Angst
und Unsicherheit und raubt den Menschen
auch die individuelle Freiheit deshalb
hat die Ampel auch schon geliefert in
zwei entlastungspaketen
haben wir schon über 30 Milliarden Euro
an Entlastungen bereitgestellt neben
einmaligen Effekten die
energiepreispauschale beispielsweise
wurde abgeschafft haben wir natürlich
auch
dauerhafte
energiepreispauschale wurde eingeführt
haben haben wir natürlich dauerhafte
Entlastungen beschlossen es wurde schon
gesagt der Grundfreibetrag ist
rückwirkend angepasst worden jetzt
passen wir ihn noch mal an und die
energieumlage die einspeiseumlage ist
dauerhaft abgeschafft worden jetzt das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz und ich danke
dem Bundesfinanzminister dafür dass er
dieses Gesetz sehr zügig eingebracht hat
wir gleichen damit zusätzliche
Belastungen aus die sich aus den
inflationären Bewegungen und Wirkungen
der steuerergeben und Länder und
Gemeinden verzichten zusammen auf einen
hohen Milliardenbetrag an zusätzlichen
Mehreinnahmen und weil das alles immer
so technisch klingt
sind kalte Progression es geht um den
Facharbeiter der wenn er in dem einen
Jahr 40.000 Euro verdient im nächsten
Jahr nur noch die Kaufkraft von 37.000
Euro hat und dann weiter besteuert wird
als hätte er 40.000 Euro das wollen wir
ausgleichen
und wir bauen auch eine
gerechtigkeitskomponente ein der
Tarifausgleich wird und zwar erstmalig
dort nicht vorgenommen wo die sogenannte
Reichensteuer beginnen in der
Vergangenheit ist das immer geschehen
diesmal verzichten wir darauf es muss
aber auch deutlich gemacht werden sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren dass jeder der
diese Regelung jetzt nicht mitträgt
verantwortet dass die Menschen im
unteren und mittleren Einkommensbereich
in diesem Land zusätzlich belastet
werden im kommenden Jahr und das wollen
wir verhindern
geben Sie mir noch kurz die Gelegenheit
auch auf die Kritik einzugehen absolut
profitieren immer diejenigen am meisten
die höher verdienen das ist
selbstverständlich in unserem
progressiven Steuertarif angelegt das
ist so sie können nicht progressiv
besteuern und linear entlasten das macht
keinen Sinn herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Herbert
nächste Redner ist der nächste Redner
ist Alois Rainer von der CSU
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sehr geehrte ampelkoalitionäre sie
können nichts dafür dass in der Ukraine
Krieg herrscht da kennen wir den
Aggressor mit Putin sie sind aber
verantwortlich für Alternativen zu
sorgen und nicht unser Land in ein
Finanz- und energiepolitisches Chaos zu
steuern
die das Entlastungen möglich sind zeigen
sie mit dem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz positiv für
vorzuheben sind hier unter anderem die
Anhebung des Kinderfreibetrages und des
Kindergeldes gut dass das umgesetzt wird
und mit der geplanten Änderung des
Einkommensteuertarifs haben sie zwar
sowohl die Arbeitgeberverbände als auch
die Gewerkschaften gegen sich
aufgebracht aber gut
Rentnerinnen und Rentner sowie
Studierende haben sie nun im dritten
Entlastungspaket aber immerhin auch
berücksichtigt und
ist gut dass man ich hoffe dann dass
dieser Bedarf auch richtig ankommt und
meine Damen und Herren mit der
befristeten Senkung der Mehrwertsteuer
auf sieben Prozent für Gaslieferungen
sind Sie einen unserer Forderungen
endlich nachgekommen das begrüßen wir
wenn sie es jetzt auch noch schaffen die
Stromsteuer zu senken und die allgemeine
Belastung mit dieser unsäglichen
gasumlage abzuschaffen dann würde dies
allen Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem
Land zugute kommen
aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Ampel was sie wieder vollständig
vergessen haben sind die kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen in unserem
Land die kaum von den Neuerungen
profitieren und wenn ich von den
Ankündigungen höre dann ist es schon
alles sehr sehr spannend und zur
Inflationsbekämpfung gehört nun mal in
erster Linie auch bei uns die Senkung
der Energiepreise die gasumlage wirkt
sich auf die Unternehmen aus wirkt sich
auf private Haushalte aus wirkt sich
auch auf das produzierende Gewerbe aus
die
gesenkte Mehrwertsteuer ist gut habe ich
schon gesagt aber die Unternehmen
profitieren einfach nicht davon weil sie
es in der Vorsteuer schon geltend machen
können also als unternehmenstechnisch
keine
Wirksamkeit und die gasumlage wie vorhin
schon gesagt wird am Ende der Tage bei
jedem bei jeder VerbraucherInnen bei
jedem Verbraucher auch ankommen mit
erhöhten beweisen weil es muss heute
rein betriebswirtschaftlich mal umgelegt
werden wenn ich die Kosten nicht umlege
oder es produzieren aufhöre dann wird es
irgendwann einmal Schluss mit der Firma
aber deshalb sollte man es umlegen und
ganz spannend finde ich bei der
Verstaatlichung von uniper führt es
jetzt dazu dass der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister zuerst gesagt
hat dass er
finanzverfassungsrechtliche Zweifel an
der gasumlage hat
weil nur mehr ein verstaatliches
Unternehmen von der zwangsgasumlage
profitieren würde kurz darauf verkündet
ihr aber dass die gasumlage trotz der
Verstaatlichung von uniper kommen würde
ja was denn jetzt wo wollen wir denn am
Ende der Tage hin und ich sage Ihnen
jetzt eins ich bin jetzt seit 35 Jahren
selbstständig habe zum Jahreswechsel
letzten Jahres mein Betrieb übergeben
ich hatte in den 35 Jahren meiner
Selbstständigkeit noch nie so ein
politisches Wirrwar erlebt wie wir es
zur jetzigen Zeit erleben
jetzt sage aus eigener Erfahrung die
Betriebe müssen planen können wir
brauchen jetzt wir müssen jetzt Verträge
energieverträge abschließen um die
Stromversorgung fürs kommende Jahr zu
sichern um die Gasversorgung fürs
kommende Jahr zu sichern kein Mensch
weiß kein Mensch weiß soll er jetzt ein
Stromvertrag abschließen mit den
erhöhten Strompreisen oder wie lange
soll er noch warten und wenn er länger
warten muss dann wird er in eine
Notversorgung getrieben die voraus aus
des vielfache mehr kostet deshalb sage
ich ich verstehe es nicht warum die FDP
solche Dinge mitmacht ihr wisst es doch
besser drückt etwas auf die Tube damit
es schneller geht damit in dieser
Koalition auch für die Betriebe was
vorangeht
und sie wissen es auch besser oder sie
müssten es eigentlich wissen die Politik
linke Tasche rechte Tasche reicht nicht
aus sie müssen die Probleme endlich bei
der Wurzel packen und sie wüssten auch
wie es geht da bin ich überzeugt nur
rein ideologische Gründe und
reinparteipolitische Gründe bremsen sie
um hier tätig zu werden jetzt sage ich
einmal eins das Angebot an Energie muss
vergrößert werden in allen Bereichen in
jeder erzeugungsform in jeder
erzeugungsform also über Bayern ist
vorhin schon viel genug Frau Kollegin
diskutiert worden ist auch viel genug
gesagt wann was wir in Bayern haben und
ich lade sie um die Einkommens in meine
Kommune meine Kommune ist energieautark
das sage ich Ihnen jetzt das ist
Politik und in Bayern haben wir eine
gute Energiepolitik ist vorhin schon
gesprochen worden erhöhen Sie das
Angebot steigen Sie beim Atomstrom in
die temporäre Verlängerung der
Atomenergie ein öffnen mit dem
biogasdeckel und eins sage ich Ihnen und
gebe ich Ihnen noch mit auf den weg
schauen Sie mal drauf dass die Windräder
weiterlaufen wenn auch
seltene Vögel nein wenn seltene Vögel
unterwegs sind weil dann werden nämlich
die Windräder gestoppt liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen dann könnten wir auch ein
Stück weit mehr Strom haben und
abschließend ändern sie endlich und das
wissen sie auch dass married order
System denn dann kommen wir zu einer
guten Lösung wenn sie das machen haben
sie uns an ihrer Seite vielen herzlichen
Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Rainer
[Applaus]
das nächste das nächste hat die Kollegin
Frauke Heiligenstadt SPD-Fraktion das
Wort
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine
sehr verehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der progressionsbericht liegt in der
Endfassung noch nicht vor trotzdem ist
die Bundesregierung nicht untätig und
hat im Vorgriff auf die zu erwartenden
Werte des in Kürze vorliegenden
progressionsberichtes den Vorschlag für
neue Tarifeckwerte bei der
Einkommensteuer mit diesem Gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt ich hatte bei den
Wortbeiträgen vorher insbesondere der
Kollegen der Oppositionsfraktion
manchmal das Gefühl sie reden gar nicht
über das Gesetz was wir gerade zur
Beratung vorliegt sondern über
irgendwelche anderen Themen
aber ich komme mal auf das Gesetz zurück
das uns jetzt zur Beratung vorliegt mit
der Verschiebung der Eckwerte erreichen
wir dass eine höhere Lohnentwicklung
auch bei den Menschen direkt ankommt
hierzu kommt zum Beispiel der
Grundfreibetrag wird erhöht den werden
wir anheben so werden wir den
Grundfreibetrag im Einkommensteuertarif
für 2023 auf
10.632 und für 2024 auf
10.932 Euro anheben das führt zu einer
Entlastung insbesondere der Menschen mit
niedrigeren eigenen Einkommen
außerdem wollen wir die Menschen mit
niedrigen und mittleren Einkommen in
unserem Land besonders in den Fokus
nehmen das ist nicht nur Auffassung der
Regierung sondern insbesondere auch
Auffassung natürlich der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion der Vorsitzende
des deutschen sparkassen- und
giroverbandes weist in einem Artikel der
FAZ vom
13.09.2022 auf eine besonders prekäre
Situation der kleinen und mittleren
Einkommen hin er macht deutlich dass bis
zu 60 Prozent der deutschen Haushalte
ihre gesamten verfügbaren Einkünfte
zukünftig monatlich für die reinen
Lebenshaltungskosten werden aufwenden
müssen die weiter steigenden Kosten
stellen Sie vor ungeahnte
Herausforderungen ich fasse diese
Aussage so zusammen Haushalte die
momentan weniger als 3.600 Euro netto
zur Verfügung haben
haushaltsgesamteinkommen können nichts
mehr auf die hohe Kante legen so die
Aussage das betrifft in einem in unserem
Land ein Großteil der Menschen und
deshalb kümmern wir uns auch um die
Anliegen dieser Menschen mit den
mittleren und kleinen Einkommen deshalb
ist es richtig dass wir mit den dritten
Entlastungspaket und den anderen Paketen
vorher eine Summe mit fast 100
Milliarden Euro verschiedenste Maßnahmen
zu Entlastung der Haushalte auf den Weg
gebracht haben dabei ist es in der
Koalition und insbesondere in meiner
Fraktion ganz besonders wichtig dass wir
die Menschen mit mittleren und
kleineinkommen entlasten mit dem
vorgelegten
inflationsausgleichsgesetz entlasten wir
rund 48 Millionen Menschen in der
Bundesrepublik das sind nicht nur reiche
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das sind
vor allen Dingen Menschen mit mittleren
und kleinen Einkommen wir erhöhen aber
auch unter anderem die
energiezahlen die energiepreispauschale
aus wir erhöhen die fernpendlerpauschale
wir zahlen den Kinderbonus auch
Heizkostenzuschüsse weiterhin ist die
wohngeldreform in Arbeit und das neue
Bürgergeld in Vorbereitung meine Damen
und Herren das sind die umfangreichsten
Entlastungen die wir seit jetzt
Bestehens der Bundesrepublik auf den Weg
gebracht haben und das ist wichtig für
Menschen in unserem Land
die anrührung im gestrigen
Finanzausschuss zu einem Antrag der
Union zur Inflationsbekämpfung und der
kalten Progression hat allerdings auch
gezeigt dass eine reine Verschiebung der
Eckwerte der Tarife für die Steuer und
eine Erhöhung des Grundfreibetrages
nicht ausreicht um die Benachteiligung
der niedrigen Einkommen durch die
Inflation gegenüber dem höheren
Einkommen auszugleichen benötigt das
noch weiterer Maßnahmen deshalb ist es
meiner Fraktion auch besonders wichtig
mit Direktzahlung Haushalte zu entlassen
insbesondere Familien dazu gehört zum
Beispiel der Erhöhung des Kindergeldes
das Kindergeld wird ab 1 Januar nächsten
Jahres schrittweise für das erste und
zweite Kind um 18 Euro sowie für das
dritte Kind um 12 Euro monatlich erhöht
und damit werden für das erste zweite
und dritte Kind im Jahr 2024 jeweils
einheitlich 237 Euro monatlich gezahlt
eine vierköpfige Familie mit einem Brutt
Einkommen von Zucker
56.000 Euro um eine Beispielrechnung mal
zu nennen wird mit Kindergeld und
entsprechender Tarifeckwerte
Berücksichtigung ein Entlastung von rund
600 Euro haben das ist nicht nichts
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Opposition
außerdem
hat dem erhöhen dir den kinderfrei
Betrag bei der Einkommensteuer
ich nenne das zielgerichtete Entlastung
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
die Erhöhung des Kindergeldes gilt auch
für einkommensschwache Familien wenn Sie
zum Beispiel gar keine Einkommensteuer
bezahlen ich weise nur der
Vollständigkeit halber darauf hin das
Geringverdiener auch soweit sie keine
Einkommensteuer zahlen durch die
entlastungspakete die geplante Stärkung
des Wohngeldes die geplante das geplante
Bürgergeld und die Erhöhung des
Mindestlohnes ab Beginn nächsten Monates
deutlich unterstützt werden das ist
soziale Politik für Menschen in unserem
Land meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
ich betone aber nochmals die SPD steht
dafür dass insbesondere die Menschen
entlastet werden die am meisten von der
Inflation betroffen sind und das sind
eben die Menschen mit kleinem Einkommen
wir stehen an der Seite dieser Menschen
in diesem Land wir lassen niemanden
allein denn das ist für uns eine Frage
der Gerechtigkeit
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren in
meinen letzten Redebeiträgen in diesem
Hohen Haus habe ich mich gelegentlich
auch mit den Vorschlägen der größten
Oppositionsfraktion auseinandergesetzt
ich sage Ihnen allerdings ganz ehrlich
sehr geehrter Herr Rainer oder sehr
geehrter Herr Middelberg nach der
gestrigen Anhörung im Finanzausschuss zu
ihrem
inflationsausgleichsantrag sage ich
ziehen Sie Ihren Antrag am besten zurück
eine größere Klatsche als bei dieser
Anhörung konnten sie nicht bekommen da
will ich sie auch nicht weiter quälen
und die Hinweise der hochrangigen
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
aus der gestrigen Anhörung ja noch mal
vortragen aber vielleicht nur so viel
wenn ihre Analyse schon falsch ist ihre
Analyse und das haben sie sogar
schriftlich bescheinigt bekommen
fehlerhaft ist dann sind auch die von
ihnen gezogenen Schlussfolgerungen
falsch da macht es gar keinen Sinn über
ihre Forderungen hier ständig noch
einmal zu diskutieren und es macht auch
keinen Sinn dass sie sie immer
wiederholen vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit Frauke heiligen Stadt war
das für die sozial-demokraten dafür hat
sie auch noch mal einige Details genannt
aus dem Gesetzentwurf zum
Inflationsausgleich gesetzt das ist ja
nicht nur ein höherer Freibetrag bei der
Einkommenssteuer sondern eben auch mehr
Kindergeld auch der Kinderfreibetrag
soll angehoben werden beispielsweise
jetzt hören wir Klaus stöber für die AFD
herr Präsident sehr geehrte Gäste auf
der Tribüne die jungen schnürt er einen
Entlastungspaket nach dem anderen was
natürlich nicht verraten diese
entlassungspaket ist ja kein Geschenk
sie finanzieren das ja aus unserem Sturm
ja diese linke Taschen das macht ihr die
SPD ja besonders gut und wenn ich mir
den anguckeumsatzsteuer auf Gas
reduzieren er hat sie bekämpfen die auch
nicht die Ursachen sie bekämpfen die
Symptome dieser Krise die Ursachen sind
ihre desolat Energiepolitik und die
Ursachen sind auch die vollkommen
geschadete Sanktionspolitik die in
Russland das hat jetzt nichts mit Putin
zu tun ja ich sage dass man einer
Wirklichkeit für mich ist Putin für mich
ist Putin kein Demokrat für mich ist
auch der Überfall Russlands ein
völkerrechtsrechtlicher Krieg ja aber
nach den Geigen Maßstab müssten sie auch
sagen der Überfall der USA werden Lamm
und die Irak warum völliger Krieg und
sie entlastend private Verbraucher aber
gleichzeitig gleichzeitig drücken Sie
ihn mit der gasumlage eine neue
Belastung obendrauf das ist viel höher
die Belastung durch die gasumlage als
das was die Bürger einsparen durch die
Reduzierung der Umsatzsteuer wenn man
dann sieht der konzernuniper der
besonders von dieser Gas-
Konzern ja wenn sie da in die Unterlagen
reingucken das wissen Sie ja vielleicht
einer der Aufsichtsratsmitglieder ist
Herr Philipp Rösler ja viele brösler
ehemaliger Vorsitzender der FDP
langwierigen finanzwirtschaftsminister
und vielleicht Herr Lindner erklären Sie
uns dabei Gelegenheit mal ob sie mit
jedem letzten acht Wochen auf das mal
telefoniert haben
feststell doch eins mit der
uniper-übernahme jetzt die staatlichung
der uniper Übernahme werden noch die
Kosten noch viel sehr höher bisher haben
wir nur gesprochen von der Ausgleich des
Verlustes von 2012 Milliarden jetzt
müssen wir noch einen Kaufpreis von 9
Milliarden finanzieren und wir müssen
acht Milliarden eine Start Finnland so
zahlen hat diese ein Darlehen und dieses
Unternehmen gegeben haben also wir
kommen jetzt nun auf 30 Milliarden und
da kann man schon mal drüber nachdenken
dass wir wahrscheinlich im Dezember hier
sitzen nur eine höhere Erhöhung der
Gasanlage sprechen
und ich sage Ihnen eines die
umsatzsteuersenkungen die kommen
vielleicht beim privaten Verbraucher an
aber nicht bei dem Unternehmen ich war
letzte Woche bei Unternehmen in Schule
eine Gesenkschmiede ist ja
energientensiv deren Abschlag monatliche
Abschlag erhöht sich um 15.000 auf
50.000 Euro nur beim Strom ja und in
meinen Ort haben zum 30.09 der
zweitbäcker ihre Geschäft geschlossen
habe gute Sachen dann ist sie nicht
pleite gegangen die haben einfach nur
zugemacht das stimmt in dem Fall auch ja
die haben rechtzeitig zugemacht aber
damit geht nicht nur Arbeitsplätze
verloren damit geht auch Identität und
Tradition in unseren Ort verloren und
das durch diese ganzen Sanktionen
gerechtfertigt ist das möchte ich mal
ein Zweifel ziehen und eins will ich
Ihnen auch sagen diese Regierung hat es
geschafft in einem Jahr uns in die
größte Krise seit 1928 zu bringen und
ich kann ihnen auch eins sagen die
Proteste auf den Straßen und die werden
das zu führen dass diese Regierung
diesen Winter nicht überleben wird und
Herr Merz ein Wort noch an sie sie
hatten ja das kritisiert
die Montagsdemonstrationen ich kann
Ihnen eines sagen das sind keine
rechtliche demonstrieren das sind ganz
einfacher Bürger die die Nase voll haben
von dieser Regierung danke schön
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Herr Kollege stöber
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin
Katharina Beck Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sie sind ganz politische Sprecherin der
Bündnisgrünen Fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz und damit
auch der Abbau der kalten Progression
ist ein großer Bestandteil des 65 65
milliardenschweren entlastungspakets 3
es geht hier um die hohen
Preissteigerungen und die Antwort des
Staates darauf wie er den Menschen
helfen kann diese abzufedern und da
wundere ich mich auch über ihr Staats-
und steuerverständnis Herr Mittelberg
das doch sehr abwertend formuliert war
denn es geht hier darum wirklich
Menschen zu helfen und nicht dass der
Staat sich irgendwie bereichert es ist
wichtig dabei ein Augenmerk auf das
immense soziale Ausmaß dieser aktuellen
Krise und der damit einhergehenden
Inflation zu legen das Ausmaß einer
Krise die das möchte ich hier ganz klar
sagen von Putin und Russland ausgelöst
wird aber die Ursache für unsere
Probleme und auch die hohen Preise liegt
auch in einer verheerenden naiven
Energiepolitik unserer
Vorgängerregierung
die uns bis zur Unerträglichkeit von
eben diesen Putin und seinem Gas
abhängig gemacht hat und die Ampel
arbeitet jetzt mit aller Kraft gemeinsam
daran uns unabhängig zu machen und eben
diese Ursachen für die hohen Preise
ihrer schlechten Energiepolitik zu
bekämpfen dass wir im Gasbereich trotz
Lieferstopp nun über 90 Prozent
Füllstände haben ist ein krasser
Verdienst unseres Wirtschafts- und
energieministers Robert Habeck und
unserer gesamten ampelregierung der
massive Ausbau der Erneuerbaren wird
mittelfristig auch zu Preissenkungen
führen der freiheitsenergien und uns
zukunftsfähig aufstellen
die akute soziale Lage in Deutschland
ist leider bestürzend laut einer
insa-befragung verzichten bereits 16
Prozent der Menschen in Deutschland
aufgrund der hohen Inflation auf
regelmäßige Mahlzeiten weitere 13%
denken darüber nach schauen Sie sich
hier einmal um und stellen Sie sich das
mal vor jeder Tritte hier im Raum hätte
aufgrund von Geldknappheit Probleme oder
Sorgen geregelt zu essen in Deutschland
ist das leider aktuell Realität die
Lebensmittelpreise sind explodiert hinzu
kommen die noch stärker explodierenden
Energiekosten die vielen Existenzsorgen
machen und am härtesten trifft dies die
rund 40 Prozent der Deutschen die
überhaupt gar keine Rücklagen haben ca
33 Millionen Menschen es trifft die die
kleinere und mittlere Einkommen haben
und auch bisher schon zum Teil aufgrund
der hohen Mietkosten kaum etwas
zurücklegen konnten weil sie die Mieten
haben so explodieren lassen aufgrund
ihres Einkommens haben sie keinen
Spielraum des abzupuffern und deswegen
fokussieren wir als nachher auf die
kleineren und mittleren Einkommen und
entlasten die in einem Gesamtpaket was
sehr sehr gut ist die Wahrheit ist ja
leider auch schon vor der Krise ging es
nicht allen gut die Ungleichheit in
diesem Land ist ja strukturell wir haben
diese Regierung übernommen in einem
Deutschland in dem jedes fünfte Kind in
Kinderarmut lebt jedes fünfte Kind in
dem Land dass das führt reichste der
Welt ist da kann man wirklich
erschüttert sein dass sie das so
hinterlassen haben
von beschäftigt an die Ampel handelt mit
großer Verantwortung 65 Milliarden
Entlastungen zusätzlich zu 30 Milliarden
aus den ersten beiden Paketen zudem
Wirtschaftshilfen in immensen Ausmaß
denn Deutschland muss auch zukunftsfähig
bleiben und gleichwohl das muss ganz
klar gesagt werden diese Krise ist so
groß wir können als Politik nicht
komplett alles abfedern im Moment unsere
Priorität muss auf der Abfederung der
größten Härten liegen und da ist es
bekannt dass wir Grüne im Sommer die
Vorschläge zum Abbau der kalten
Progression kritisiert haben denn
alleine nur dieser Vorschlag hätte wenig
verdiente viermal so wenig entlasse wie
viel verdiente im Paket mit den anderen
Maßnahmen ist das Ergebnis aber nun dass
tatsächlich am unteren Ende vier
entlastet wird Beispiel eine
Alleinerziehung Erziehende mit einem
Kind auf Basis von Berechnungen der
Universität Nürnberg
869 Euro übers Jahr wird diese entlastet
mit nur 1000 Euro Einkommen pro Monat
und
Alleinerziehende mit 6500 Euro pro Monat
765 Euro im Jahr bei weniger niedrigen
und mittleren Einkommen ist noch etwas
zu tun aber die Richtung stimmt und dazu
trägt beispielsweise die im
Koalitionsausschuss verhandelte Anhebung
der Kindergelderhöhung auf 18 Euro bei
und auch die erneute Anhebung des
Grundfreibetrags beide schon Teil dieses
Gesetzes wichtig ist dass wir auch bald
noch die vereinbarte Anhebung des
Kinderzuschlags auf den Weg bringen und
uns gut aufstellen für Deutschland
wirklich notwendige Kindergrundsicherung
vielen Dank
ich möchte nur darauf hinweisen bevor
ich im nächsten reden das Wort gehe wenn
jeder Redner zwischen 30 und 40 Sekunden
überzieht sind wir um 3 Uhr heute Nacht
erst fertig das will ja mit Sicherheit
keiner von ihnen nächste Redner ist der
Kollege natürlich das
Bundestagspräsidium sehr drauf den die
Tagesordnung heute tatsächlich die geht
jetzt schon bereits bis in den späteren
Abend
Johannes Steininger für die
Unionsfraktion jetzt mich an die Zeit zu
halten meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren endlich legt das
Bundesfinanzministerium hier diesen
Antrag vor diesen dieses Gesetz vor es
ist ehrlich gesagt überfällig wir als
cdu/csu wir kritisieren das Problem der
kalten Progression insbesondere für das
aktuelle Jahr 2022 seit Dezember letzten
Jahres und Herr Minister Lindner ich
beglückwünsche Sie ich beglückwünsche
auch die Kollegen Kollegen der FDP dass
sie sich in dieser Ampel durchgesetzt
haben dass dieses Gesetz jetzt kommt
denn es stand nicht im Koalitionsvertrag
und wir haben doch heute und wir haben
doch heute gehört in der Diskussion
eigentlich ist es doch so
Grüne und SPD wollen dieses Gesetz
eigentlich nicht das haben wir doch
heute gehört Grüne und SPD wollen dieses
Gesetz eigentlich nicht sie wollen
eigentlich die kalte Progression sie
wollen diese heimlichen Steuererhöhung
sie wollen die Umverteilung deswegen
sind wir froh dass die FDP in der Ampel
mit dabei ist
aber gleichzeitig aber gleichzeitig muss
man schon sagen es ist jetzt auch kein
Grund sich hier abzufeiern für dieses
Gesetz dieses Gesetz ist eine totale
Selbstverständlichkeit seine totale
Selbstverständlichkeit weil es im
übrigen Herr Minister auch nicht Teil
der Krisenbewältigung ist sondern wir
sorgen hier dafür dass es also es sind
keine Entlastung sondern wir sorgen ja
dafür dass nicht weiter belastet wird
und das ist doch alles nur in Ordnung
dass das auch so gemacht wird es kann ja
wohl nicht meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren liebe Kollegen es kann doch nicht
sein dass Menschen die sowieso schon
massiv in diesem Land von der Inflation
gebeutelt sind dann auch noch dem Staat
mehr Steuern zahlen deswegen ist es gut
dass es hier passiert aber aus dem
zweiten Grund ist es für uns auch
selbstverständlich wir als Union haben
das in den letzten Jahren immer gemacht
wir haben diese Gesetze gemacht wir
haben es 2018 gemacht 10 Milliarden Euro
Entlastung wir haben es 2020 gemacht 12
Milliarden Euro Entlastung wir hätten es
auch jetzt gemacht wenn wir dran wären
und Frau Beck sie haben das Thema
Kinderarmut angesprochen ein wirklich
wichtiges Thema dem wir uns annehmen
müssen als Politik aber sie erhöhen
jetzt hier das Kindergeld um 18 Euro wir
haben es in der letzten Legislatur um 25
Euro erhöht also was wollen Sie ja
eigentlich in dieser Diskussion
und jetzt im Einzelnen jetzt wird der
Tarif auf Rädern auch vom Minister
wieder entdeckt das war für uns
überhaupt nicht notwendig als wir dran
waren weil wir es halt einfach gemacht
haben und dann wird hier auch noch
gesagt dann wird hier auch noch gesagt
2022 wäre einiges gemacht worden sie
haben den Grundfreibetrag erhöht sie
haben aber nichts an den anderen
Eckwerten für dieses Jahr gemacht das
heißt diese Bundesregierung hat im
Grunde genommen in diesem Jahr
Steuererhöhung eingeführt über die kalte
Progression und das lassen wir ihn nicht
durchgehen und deswegen adressieren wir
das hier auch
wir schlagen Ihnen im übrigen vor in
diesen Zeiten in denen die Inflation
jetzt auch hoch bleiben wird und in der
sich die Inflation ändern wird dass wir
das Verfahren ändern dass wir den
progressionsbericht nicht mehr alle zwei
Jahre vorlegen sondern jedes Jahr um
hier zu besseren Anpassungen zu kommen
da freue ich mich auch auf die
Diskussion die wir dann im Ausschuss
dazu haben werden
ich habe mir überlegt ob ich dieses
Thema anspreche weil ich mich schon
gewundert habe im Sommer als die gesamte
Diskussion zu diesem Gesetz ja schon am
Laufen war hat der Bundesfinanzminister
Lindner auf einmal ein framing benutzt
was ich jetzt von ihm eigentlich nicht
erwartet hätte er hat nämlich von der
Reichensteuer gesprochen also von dem
letzten Eckwert der wird hier nicht
verändert und ich kann das verstehen
dass man dieser Versuchung sozusagen
dann auch nachgeht etwas populäres zu
machen aber ich erinnere mich noch sehr
gut an Diskussion zum
Solidaritätszuschlag als sie immer
wieder gesagt haben die Einkommensteuer
ist die Unternehmenssteuer für ganz
viele Betriebe in Deutschland das heißt
wenn Sie diesen Eckwert nicht verändern
dann haben Sie hier eine heimliche
Steuererhöhung für viele Unternehmen in
Deutschland und das geht so nicht
in der letzten in der letzten Minute die
mir noch bleibt möchte ich zum zweiten
Teil dieses gesetzesstellung nehmen das
ist die Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf den
Bereich Gas und meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wer wieder Kanzler Olaf
Scholz sagt Jul never walk alone der
muss dann auch endlich all in gehen der
muss all in gehen beim Angebot der muss
all in gehen bei den Kernkraftwerken der
muss All-In gehen bei der Kohle der muss
All-In gehen bei Biomasse Biogas
erneuerbaren und der muss auch all in
gehen bei den Entlastungen beim Thema
Stromsteuer beim Thema Energiesteuer
hier müssen wir all in gehen um die
Menschen in diesem Land zu entlasten
dieser dieses Gesetz ist eine
Selbstverständlichkeit wir werden diese
auch unterstützen und ansonsten stehen
wir für gute Beratung bereit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege steiniger das
war ja vorbildlich mit der Zeit ja das
war vorbildlich Zeit sagt der Bundestag
ist Vizepräsident Kubicki er freut sich
wenn ihr halbwegs die Redezeiten
angehalten wir denn und man hier mit der
avisierten Zeit dann auch zurecht kommt
ja zwei Gesetzentwürfe liegen hier diese
Debatte ja zugrunde nicht nur das
inflationsausgleichgesetz sondern eben
auch die durch die Senkung der
Mehrwertsteuer bzw Umsatzsteuer auf
Gaslieferung von derzeit 19 auf 7
Prozent das auch in erster Lesung ja
übrigens Tim klyssendorf für die SPD
weil alles was Sie heute gesagt haben
ist das Gesetz ist eine
Selbstverständlichkeit wir würden das
auch so machen einiges gar nicht so
schlimm also mir fehlt so ein bisschen
ich meine wir haben die größte
Wirtschafts- und finanzpolitische
Herausforderung in der Geschichte dieser
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und das
einzige was sie hier tun ist
festzustellen dass die Regierung richtig
handelt einen besseren Arbeitsnachweis
für uns kann es eigentlich kaum geben
Stellung nehmen möchte ich allerdings
doch noch mal zum Kollegen stöber Herr
stöber sie haben eben gesagt diese
Bundesregierung hat die schlimmste Krise
seit 1928 zu verursachen
es ist wieder einmal
geschichtsverleumdung der ganz schlimmen
Sorte wer den Zeitraum zwischen 1933 und
1945 so bewusst ausblendet und damit
kokettiert der gehört nicht nur hier in
die rechte Ecke der gehört aus diesem
Parlament und vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet so wie es auch jetzt gerade
passiert
ich habe eben schon davon gesprochen
welche Herausforderungen momentan vor
uns stehen die Bundesregierung handelt
entschlossen wir haben drei
anlassungspakete auf den Weg gebracht
die insgesamt rund 100 Milliarden Euro
umfassen deswegen auch noch mal zum
Thema Selbstverständlichkeit ich hatte
nicht den Eindruck dass das
selbstverständlich ist in so einem hohen
Ausmaß so schnell zu reagieren vor allen
Dingen in Anbetracht der Tatsache dass
wir noch nicht mal ein Jahr im Amt sind
deshalb muss man auch noch mal ganz
ehrlich sagen uns wird es nicht gelingen
alle Belastungen zu kompensieren aber
doch mit den Paketen die wir bisher
beschlossen haben ist ein ganz
wesentlicher Schritt getan worden und
darauf können wir stolz sein und daran
werden wir weiterarbeiten
wir entlasten natürlich nicht nur aktiv
sondern wir wollen auch nicht an den
höheren Preisen verdienen das wurde auch
richtig angesprochen deswegen
Bestandteil dieser beiden
Gesetzesvorschläge ist der Abbau der
kalten Progression und deswegen Herr
steiniger das ist etwas was wir richtig
finden sie brauchen uns nicht einzureden
was wir wollen oder was wir nicht wollen
das haben wir gemeinsam als
Ampelkoalition verabredet und wir stehen
da auch vollständig hinter
aber ich möchte doch auch die
Gelegenheit nutzen und zum zweiten Punkt
noch mal etwas sagen nämlich temporäre
Senkung der Umsatzsteuer auf
Gaslieferung wir senken bereits zum
kommenden Monat das heißt zum Beginn der
Heizperiode die Mehrwertsteuer auf
Gaslieferung von 19% auf 7 %. und das
einfach so abzutun dass das ja nur die
gasumlage irgendwie ausgleicht oder nur
eine Kompensationsmaßnahme ist ich meine
gerade vor dem Hintergrund der aktuellen
Debatten über die gasumlage und die
möglicherweise noch Anpassung die es
dort geben wird ist das eine ganz
wesentliche entlastungsmaßnahme die
nicht vernachlässigt werden darf und die
ihren ganz eigenen Wert hat
insgesamt umfasst allein diese Maßnahme
schließlich rund 11 Milliarden Euro und
ist damit auch eine der größten
Einzelmaßnahmen aus den drei
entlastungspaketen rot die Hälfte aller
Haushalte in Deutschland Heizen mit Gas
und sind konfrontiert mit so oft
gaspreissteigerung von mehreren hundert
Prozent im Durchschnitt verdoppelt sich
der Gaspreis für viele mindestens diese
Maßnahme die Umsatzsteuer zu senken
wirkt also nicht nur entlastend sondern
senkt auch ganz effektiv die
Inflationsrate in unserem Land und ist
deshalb auch weiterhin richtig
selbstverständlich darf es aber hierbei
nicht bleiben und deswegen auch noch mal
ein paar Worte insgesamt zu
Gaspreisentwicklung wir haben dazu schon
einiges gehört der Bundesfinanzminister
ist darauf eingegangen es wird natürlich
noch weitere Maßnahmen brauchen um die
Menschen vor den und auch die
Unternehmen natürlich die kleinen
mittleren Unternehmen ganz besonders vor
diesen höheren Gaspreisen zu schützen
und ihnen sozusagen zu ermöglichen dass
Ihre Rechnung bezahlen können aus meiner
Sicht und aus unserer Sicht kann das
eigentlich nur über eine Deckelung der
Gaspreise führen und deshalb bin ich
ganz gespannt wie schnell und wie
entschlossen auch die Kommission da
jetzt agieren wird und da werden wir
auch weiterhin ordentlich Druck machen
denn wir werden die Menschen nicht
alleine lassen wir müssen dringend an
die Gaspreise weiter ran und das kann
heute nur ein Auftakt einer Entlastung
sein
doch lassen sie mich ganz zum Schluss
noch etwas zu Finanzierung sagen das
wird natürlich auch weiterhin mit
enormen Anstrengung und hohen
Milliardensummen in der Finanzierung
verbunden sein und eine ganz persönliche
Anmerkung ich verstehe es nicht unsere
Gesellschaft hat genug Wohlstand um
diese ganzen Herausforderungen zu
finanzieren dieser Wohlstand ist zurzeit
nur ungerecht verteilt wir haben die
mittlerweile die zweithöchste
Konzentration von Vermögen in von allen
OECD-Staaten und deshalb bin ich auch
dafür dass wir uns in den kommenden
Wochen und Monaten wenn wir über solche
gaspreisdecken und ähnliche sprechen
auch noch mal der Frage der Finanzierung
widmen wir alle gemeinsam die ganze
Gesellschaft in einem breiten Konsens
denn ich glaube ohne eine höhere
Beteiligung der besonders vermögenden
werden wir diese Krise nicht finanzieren
können ich danke Ihnen für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
küssendorf für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
ja das inflationsausgleichsgesetz
die Abfederung der kalten Progression
das hat die Ampelkoalition in das dritte
Entlastungspaket eingerechnet aber das
Vorhaben hätte sowieso aus der
Tagesordnung gestanden Sebastian Schäfer
jetzt für die Grünen letzter Redner zu
diesem Tagesordnungspunkt
dass wir in der aktuellen Krise den
Umsatzsteuersatz auf Gas senken bei den
aktuellen Preisen sind die Anreize zum
Energiesparen sehr stark und für viele
VerbraucherInnen sind diese Preise aber
eine Überforderung
daher ist eine Entlastung die direkt bei
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern landet
notwendig und die umsatzsteuersenkung
ist der Teil eines viel größeren
entlastungspakets das wurde in der
Debatte ausführlich thematisiert
die umsatzsteuersenkung hilft aber
unseren Unternehmen nicht wer in den
Wahlkreisen unterwegs ist wer gerade mit
kleineren Unternehmen oder mit
Handwerksbetrieben spricht ist mit
dramatischen Botschaften konfrontiert
die Unternehmen haben existenzielle
Sorgen wie sie die Energiekosten
bezahlen sollen mit denen sie
konfrontiert sind in einem
wirtschaftsstarken mittelständisch
industriell geprägten Wahlkreis wie
meinem in Esslingen geht es darum den
Kern unserer Volkswirtschaft
und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck angekündigt
hat die bereits bestehenden
Wirtschaftshilfen für die
energieintensive Industrie nun auch auf
das Handwerk und den Mittelstand
auszuweiten
deshalb ist es dringend notwendig dass
es in der Bundesregierung jetzt auch die
Bereitschaft dafür gibt diese
Wirtschaftshilfen mit einer
ausreichenden Finanzierung auszustatten
die in diesem Herbst und Winter dringend
notwendigen wirtschaftlichen Hilfen
dürfen nicht an mangelnder Finanzierung
scheitern
wir sehen in der Krise ganz besonders
wie komplex die Wertschöpfungsketten in
unserer Volkswirtschaft sind und welche
extremen Konsequenzen Ausfälle in diesen
Wertschöpfungsketten haben können wir
bekommen jetzt eine gigantische Rechnung
präsentiert für das energiepolitische
Versagen früherer Bundesregierungen
billiges russisches pipeline-gas wird es
absehbar nicht mehr geben die hohen
Preise werden auch im Frühjahr nicht
einfach vorbei sein
Gas brauchen wir in unserer
Volkswirtschaft ja nicht nur zum Heizen
von Wohnungen sondern das ist ein
wichtiges Vorprodukt gerade für die
Prozesse in unserer chemischen Industrie
das können wir nicht überall
substituieren deshalb fordert der
Verband der chemischen Industrie
bekanntlich keine grüne
Vorfeldorganisation und mit Verlaub per
Präsident ich darf aus der FAZ zitieren
das Geld wird der Staat sowieso ausgeben
müssen besser jetzt in die Struktur als
nächstes Jahr zur Finanzierung der
Arbeitslosigkeit
wir sehen jetzt auch bei den
Steuereinnahmen was los ist am aktuellen
Rand im August haben wir da einen
deutlichen Rückgang ich fürchte das ist
eine Trendwende die
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute senken
ihre Wachstumsprognosen immer weiter ab
wir brauchen entschlossenes Handeln der
Bundeskanzler hat in dieser schweren
Krise die konzertierte Aktion
wiederbelebt
ich wünsche mir diesen Geist der
Zusammenarbeit auch zwischen den
staatlichen Ebenen herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Schäfer und
damit ist die Aussprache beendet bevor
wir
weiterfahren der Kollege stöber hat mich
gebeten an Erklärung gemäß paragra auf
30 Geschäftsordnung abgeben zu dürfen
hintergrund ist ein Äußerung des
Kollegen küssendorf wonach
die Zeit zwischen 33 und 45 ausgebildet
worden sei und deshalb sie so war die
Formulierung nicht in diese Parlamente
ins Parlament gehören und auf
verfassungsbeobachten beobachtet werden
dürfen ich habe das persönlich so
verstanden dass er mir die AFD insgesamt
gemeint gewesen ist aber man kann es
passieren man kann es auch als
persönlichen Angriff verstehen deshalb
erlaube ich die
Erklärung zur Aussprache für den
Kollegen stöber Klaus stöber also von
der AFD Düsseldorf
meine Aussage dass ich 1928 als die
letzte große Krise betrachtet haben und
hier ist die nächste Krise eingeleitet
haben
behauptet ich hatte das die Zeit von
1933 bis 45 ausgeklammert das muss ich
zurückweisen
mein Großvater war verfolgt das
Nationalsozialismus und ich denke mal
das schließt schon mal automatisch aus
dass ich
irgendwelche Sympathien für diese Zeit
Hege und auch für diese Person die
damals regiert haben ja und deswegen ist
sie auch Aussage aus meiner Sicht nicht
zutreffend danke
vielen Dank eine Aussprache hier zu in
der Video ist nicht vorgesehen
interfraktionellen liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen wird Überweisung der
Gesetzentwürfe auf Drucksachen 3.496 und
3.530 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Autos
Vizepräsident Wolfgang Kubicki also die
Gesetzentwürfe die beiden die dieser
letzten Debatte hier diesen
debattenpunkt zugrunde
gelegen haben in die Ausschüsse
überweisen also das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz mit den
Punkten die kalte Progression abzufedern
mit einer Erhöhung des Kindergeldes mit
einer Anhebung des Kinderfreibetrages
und mit einem höheren
Unterhaltsbeitrag beispielsweise und
auch den Gesetzentwurf in dem es ja
darum geht die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas
als Ausgleich von Mehrbelastung durch
die geplante Gasanlage von Oktober bis
Ende März 2024 zusenden